i snapped i had three
strokes i had a heart attack my doctors
said that i had five to ten more minutes
for the very first time demi reveals
what led up to her 2018 overdose
the night before demi alleges she was
sexually assaulted by the man she refers
to as her drug dealer
she claims he left her unconscious and
naked at home
her assistant found her called 9-1-1 and
her family rushed to the hospital where
demi was near death
i said what do you mean if she's going
to make it you're watching all of her
blood come
out of her body into a machine what were
those interviews like
tough i mean you know sitting down with
her stepfather and mother and
talking about the situation where they
really
believe that they may lose their
daughter is difficult you could just see
the pain as they sort of relived it
i got to put my recovery first in front
of everything else and
because without my recovery i wouldn't
have this today the singer has often
shared with e.t how important it was for
her to stay sober
but after demi spent about two weeks in
the hospital where her family thought
she would die
she went and did heroin again with the
same alleged drug dealer who she claimed
sexually assaulted her
michael who spent an entire year with
demi making this four part series
confronts the 28 year old directly about
her sobriety
why is this one different why should we
believe you and she gives a really great
answer
where she says you're gonna have to wait
and see because i'm i'm working on it
daily
[Music]
i don't know it's hard to grow up in
front of people demi started using
cocaine and other substances around the
time she was 16 which is also when she
now claims she lost her virginity to
rape
i've really struggled with this are you
entirely sober now
[Music]
the big reveal at the end is that demi
is not sober
she is drinking and smoking weed in
moderation
this is her truth and she's not saying
it's perfect she's saying that she's
figuring it out i'm not living my life
for other people or their headlines or
their twitter comments